what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 29th
of september a beautiful [__] day to
be alive from the heart of jersey the
joint is brought to you by [__]
draftkings listen
three weeks are in the books now it's
time
to review the [__] tape
football is at a [__] peak now you
understand me you know if you're gonna
win you know what the teams are made of
and you know the breakup i'm looking
forward to you know me i bet heavy on
anybody who plays the jets it's that
simple the jets are [__] terrible but
i'm looking forward to a couple games
this week i'm looking forward to atlanta
against washington i'm looking forward
to it miami against the colts
and monday night is a [__] tremendous
game who the [__] do we have monday
night we got the [__] raiders
against the chargers listen to me
draftkings has an offer that's bananas
they're giving all new customers 150
instantly just bet a dollar on any
football game
college nfl
pop warner i don't give a [__] you heard
me [__] head to draft king
sportsbook app
now that one dollar and get 150 and free
bets instantly if sportsbook is not
available in your state no [__]
problems draftking still has huge cash
prizes for grabs with their daily
fantasy contest
however you play draftkings is giving
all new customers a free shot at
millions of dollars in total prizes with
their first deposit you can't beat that
that's why i'm with draftkings i love
them
i [__] work with them i love them i
place bets whether it's the casino the
roulette the the blackjack
baseball football basketball college
basketball college football hockey
download the draftking sportsbook app
now use promo code joey to get you a
hundred and fifty dollars in free bets
when you place a dollar on any football
game that's promo code joey
draftkings the official sports betting
partner the nfl new jersey indiana
pennsylvania west virginia colorado
new customers only minimum five hour
deposit one dollar wager
restrictions apply see draftkings
dot com sports book for details now if
you got a gammon prom we don't want you
on draftkings take care of your problems
call 1-800 gambler if you're in indiana
call 1-809 with it but if you got no
problems and everything's ready to go
draftking sportsbook app is waiting for
you like i said whether it's mma
bellator ufc nfl draftkings has you
covered this weekend better dollar to
win 150 dollars
and knock yourself out with draftkings
[__]
the joint is also brought to you by me
undies
boo it's four [__] that means you'll
be pissing in your pants one way or
another it's a spooky time of the month
you're going to a haunted house or
you're drinking too much at a [__]
game go ahead and ruin your pants you
can buy some fresh ones from new undies
me on these new undies i don't know what
the [__] let me tell you something about
me undies they're tremendous
they're made
with this cotton that is breathable
they're so [__] comfortable i have
been wearing me on these for the last
six years and that's all i wear
whether you're out running a killer or
being abducted by aliens this halloween
at least you'll have a fresh pair on
listen to the names of some of these
prints they got i see you my boo
trick and treats i like that one lazy
bones and the lazy pumpkin meundies are
designed to be the softest thing on
earth softening the baby's butt
softening the feather how meundie's
signature micro maldow fabric literally
grows
from trees that means that these undies
are soft and sustainable what's better
than that
nothing it's like a little baby's hand
holding your nut sack nice and
comfortable they offer a million sizes
from extra small through 4x different
cuts for different butts is their motto
get some bras socks and loungewear you
know me i love me undies get 15 off your
first order and free shipping
and 100
money back guarantee at meundies.com
joey that's meundies.com
joey you better make a decision quickly
because there's somebody behind you
i made you look [__] meundies.com
[Music]
joey
i'm gonna give you 15 off your first
order and free shipping and 100 money
back guarantee you can't get that
anywhere the joint is also brought to
you by my personal favorite
wait till you get to be 58 years old
you're going to be drinking the cbd
[__] cream whether it's the cream
whether it's the gel the bath balls the
kinesiology tape
the capsules the gummy bears
the tincture let me tell you something
i've been taking a thousand fifteen
hundred milligram tincture
since i started acupuncture
just because you're in it to win it oh
my god i feel [__] great i sleep like
a baby my pains are gone i mean i'm
getting old you're not gonna beat that
but for temporary relief of pains aches
i put a piece of tape up that
kinesiology tape on my knee i'm good to
[__] go for 10 hours
listen go to cbd line read the third
party lab results knock yourself out
this is a real deal holyfield you're not
buying cbd or some [__] guy that
doesn't even know how the [__] oxygen is
so do yourself a favor go to cbdline.com
read
i want you to read and learn about cbd
cbn and cby
and how it can be advantageous to you
right now go to cbdline.com read up
try start off with the caps you're going
to be [__] amazed how well you're
gonna feel
press and co joey
and get 20 off
the normal price
delivered right to your [__]
crib that's cbdlion.com
joey get 20 off your order delivered
right to your [__] house it's
wednesday the 29th let's get this
[__] party started [__]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 29th it's almost
[__] over i was telling mike dear dad
i was driving minding my own business
not bothering anybody
and i must hit the wrong button on
serious it must have been the station
for bad music
because they put on a [__] yoko ono
song and let me tell you something
i told mike the only proper response was
to [__] crash the [__] car guys
it was brutal brutal
brutal
brutal i don't know about you guys but
oh my god she was going
and i'm like driving trying to figure it
out you know like when you freeze up and
you can't press it's like getting like
you ever get your your fingers stuck in
something and you freeze up for like
three minutes you don't know what to do
you pull away and it hurts more you put
i couldn't even figure out the radio i'm
like get this [__] yoko ono off my
[__] thing
listen i don't have asians i just hate
yoko ono i don't want people to say well
you're making fun of no it's just yoko i
ate chinese food yesterday you know me
dog i gotta eat my [__]
every [__] week i got a chinese
restaurant down the corner i'm there
twice a week if you think i'm [__]
with you tremendous i get the three
flavor shrimp holy [__] with black bean
sauce on some [__] rice i only eat a
half a cup of rice my points plus to
spice up your [__] diabetes
oh they're [__] tremendous i've
always liked chinese food i think that's
the happiest i'm about is that i have
chinese food at my disposal and if this
restaurant down the block is closed
walking distance the one [__] closer
to my house is even better than this one
they have different things that are good
than i like i like the pork fried rice
over here i like the egg drop soup i
like three flavors shrimp that other
place has tremendous
shrimp egg foo young i mean [__] old
school shrimp egg food young you put
some sauce on that [__] it's all
protein it's shrimp and egg you can't
[__] lose your dick gets [__]
harder than arithmetic jack
but i'm good i had a good weekend
i had a good monday a good [__]
tuesday
acupuncture i'm back
i'm back with the ack and you could tell
that was the last of my many [__] uh
things i hadn't done
from la i'm back steady that was my
fourth thing my fourth session i also
went to jiu jitsu last week and i'm
gonna join the class i'm gonna take
another private or two and then maybe
start going to the class because i'm out
of [__] breathing shape i mean i'm in
shape i've been lifting weights and
jumping up and down and all that [__]
but uh
i'm not in jiu jitsu shape but i'm happy
i went thank you guys for encouraging me
to go a bunch of people like when are
you going back to jiu jitsu and i felt
kind of [__]
shitty about it but i just had [__]
knee surgery you know i can't be jumping
up and [__] down right now so i
wanted it to get settled
i'm still having a hard time riding the
bike around the neighborhood but i ride
the stationary bike and
you know i'm okay for now i'm dead
lifting i'm squatting you know so i just
can't kneel
you know so i can't give [__] blow
jobs that sucks but what are you gonna
[__] do how come chicks that get
[__] don't get [__] up knees
just [__] guys i can't kneel on him i
had to put a brace and a [__] knee
pad and the right knee hurt but you know
what the more i go the more i'll get
used to it and whatnot
[__] uh bet against the jets listen i
don't have any betting
uh knowledge for you guys i'm dumb when
it comes to that i don't know who's
pitching i don't know the quarterback of
the team i gotta ask jimmy and his son
his son gives me the best because kids
know about what's going on so if i'm on
a better football team or something i'll
ask his kid this week i didn't know who
to bet so i just bet against [__] the
jets because listen that terrible number
one i mean that god awful the starting
quarterback went down and number two
they were playing denver in denver on
the lord's day everybody knows that's an
automatic and [__] four o'clock game
[__] that's when denver [__] thrives
on the lord's day on a sunday nice the
sun was out no snow boom it was like 17
nothing at the half i was happy i only
bet [__] 25 bucks but hey [__] 25
bucks is 25 bucks where i come from what
did you win on sunday that's what i'm
talking about
i'm just trying to have a good time here
today that's it it's all about having a
good time smiling having some fun
i was telling the people on the patreon
podcast
that sunday i went over to my friend's
house and i had some [__] at the
puma's house
jody puma is one of the best [__]
cooks ever my neighbor holy [__]
she made a bolognese sauce
to make your [__] go like this you
ever have your [__] just rattled like
did you ever been driving and your
[__] just goes weep
this bolognese was so [__] good and
she made a loaf of [__] garlic bread
i had so many [__] garlic cloves on
it i almost lost my mind when i bit into
the first thing
like breadcrumbs didn't fall off it was
[__] garlic things just went all over
but i love garlic because that's when i
do my best work you understand me so i
had the three pieces of garlic bread i
had my little bowl of
i relaxed a little while and i went over
to jimmy's to watch the raiders against
miami you know jimmy florentine's a big
miami fan so when the dolphins play i go
over there and i support them i don't
i'm not a fan of anybody listen i'm a
fan of the team i go to a game with a
hat with a minus 10 on it i i i don't
have a favorite [__] team i just you
know i i don't know what i'm doing with
football so i'll go talk to them but
sunday i went over there after i ate the
[__] garlic and there was a bunch of
guys over there you know hanging out
having a good time saying [__] and one
of the guys started farting like he was
blowing these wet thoughts and i'm like
what the [__]
you know and i didn't smell them they i
couldn't smell them at all i was like
five six feet away from the dude
so at one point i'm sitting like oh i
gotta fart you know i didn't know what
was gonna come out of my ass i didn't
know the garlic had processed that fast
i blew a fart guys
that was so [__] bad
and then about eight minutes later
i blew another one that was so bad
everybody was watching the game with
their [__] nose covered that means i
[__] won people going what the [__]
is that
i fought it on the couch
i got up like a half hour later to go
pee
i peed i came back to the couch and when
i sat down the fart had gone into the
couch and it came right back out at me
like you could re-smell it again people
like you fought it again i'm like nah
the fart went into the couch and when i
sat down it blew the era and here's the
beauty i went into the bathroom a half
hour later and the bathroom still
smelled like [__] garlic from me just
walking in there after i fought it was
tremendous fart listen those garlic
farts they go into your [__] clothes
that's when you know
you did a good [__] job you
understand me they were like what the
[__] going on i saw jimmy at the gym
yesterday was like
dog those are some great [__] farts
he goes i went down there two hours
later to get something and i could still
smell the residue from it garlic farts
are always the [__] best i listen i
i love it i love them because nobody
knows they're coming out they were
silent
but deadly just how i [__] like them
this is a big week for me you guys know
what's going on this week
uh
it's a big week for [__] new jersey
i'm really proud
of uh this week on friday that many
saints annual comes out we've been
talking about it for two years
i promise you'll never hear about it
[__] again
after today unless you guys bring it up
or ask me a question or whatever
um i'm very proud of this [__] movie
for
certain [__] reasons you know
i never thought i would ever work get to
work with david chase
and that had me a little bummed not like
i'm gonna know i just it was just like
you know i never get to work with david
chase you know
in 1998 i came back here 99 i came back
here
to get him with global uh global is like
an entertainment group that booked a
bunch of rooms and [__]
i came in to get with global i came to
get with i wanted to talk to some agents
i wanted to talk to a couple of
different films like i wanted to do some
with law and order anyway
so what you usually do is you tape a set
you um
you know put your reel on there like
what movies you've been in and that's
your [__] demo reel you know when
people say to you do you have a demo
reel i could finally say yes i didn't
have anything on that this time in 98 i
think i had like a few college films and
maybe
uh
i didn't i never got the pilot from
bronx county so i just had all these
college films and my stand-up you know
and you come and you drop them off on an
envelope and a headshot and a resume and
a bio and hope they call you you know so
my buddy owned a tape duplication thing
so i went to him earlier in the day and
we duplicated a bunch of tapes and then
afternoon i went out into the city to
drop off tapes you know one of the
places that my manager had a manager at
the time great guy
he called me up he's like hey i got you
this audition for the sopranos going in
drop off the [__] tape
well i got busy dropping off the other
tapes at law and order and all these
other shows i forget
and i never made it to the sopranos and
i go you know what who gives a [__]
i'm not a singer anyway you know i can't
[__] sing i took the show as a
singing show
and then in 99 or or 2000
i went to the toyota comedy festival
and uh it was a 10 o'clock show and i
went up on stage
and the next thing you know [__] uh
one of the girls
that worked for
uh
the casting director was there
and she asked me is georgina walking
senior and i go no and she goes well
you're going to see it tomorrow at 11
o'clock in the morning that's how fast
it was i was just getting off the stage
at midnight and she's like you're going
to see it tomorrow at 11 o'clock in the
morning i go okay
so i got that 11 o'clock in the morning
i was supposed to be in buffalo i'd let
her know the truth and i'm waiting on
the street also a lady comes up to me
she's like
do me a favor go upstairs and leave a
card with your name on it you'd be
perfect for my show are you an actor and
i go i'm a stand-up
and i am perfect for your show i'm your
11 o'clock
and she goes you're joey and i never
forget we walked in we were talking i
was nervous
i was uh
you know when you get nervous and you go
for an audition
you're gawky you say [__] that you don't
want to say so i always check myself not
to get [__] nervous or something
but i remember on the elevator i said to
her can i ask you a question are you
really
christopher walken's wife and she goes
yep
and i'm like holy [__] i go can i tell
you something
i go and this was i took a chance saying
this i go i think his best movie
is at close range and she just looked at
me
and she's like you're right everybody
thinks it's a dear hunter but i lean
towards at close range you're right and
we started talking and that helped our
relationship a little bit i went in i
read
i put it on tape and she told me she
goes listen go back to acting class you
know
okay tighten up your [__] and i'll keep
in touch with you and we did i kept in
touch with over the years how you doing
joe jan i booked this
but then opportunity knocks i booked a
show a short film called the mezzos for
fox it didn't pay but it was a great
script i got to play a gay
mobster and it was good of good quality
so
i took that tape and i sent it to george
ann
and she called me within like a year and
asked me
to audition for pussy's brother i was
working on spider-man 2.
i put the audition on tape i booked it
but there was a
an issue somebody said i said something
to somebody so they fired me before i
could ever shoot was i bummed i was a
little bummed but by that time i had
already gotten acting chops and i know
that when you go to an audition just
prepare yourself do the best you can
and when you walk in [__] kick ass
when you walk out you won't have any
doubts
i was already
i had a i had already had that mind
uh set you know so when i didn't get it
i didn't get it that's nothing you could
do
god didn't want me to have it and then
two years ago somebody let me know what
they were doing a prequel i auditioned
and it was funny i still remember
packing my bag for new york
and going this is a great opportunity
for me
[Music]
everything happens for a reason in life
i got to do this movie i got to work
with david chase
before i end my career
so me getting fired
in
was like a godsend i wasn't really ready
i wasn't ready to shoot at that higher
level
and i knew that at least i was honest
with myself and i knew that
i wasn't ready in 2000 but i was ready
like a [__]
in 2019. so when i got the call
to do this at first i was a little
apprehensive
i was i had some doubts you know that's
david chase
i don't want to [__] up in front of
david chase but you know what
one of my dear friends tom popper talked
me into it and uh here we are today
september 29th uh i got a movie under my
belt
i got a great character and uh i did
great i've seen the movie three times
already
and again because of kathleen narducci i
did great i did great
i belonged there huh you lost yourself
yeah i watched myself
i looked at my timing everything was
great uh
i knew i was a gentleman on the set
i knew i did everything i was supposed
to do and i got to be honest with you
i'm going to pat myself on the back for
you guys
i'm very proud of myself and i'm very
proud that you guys
finally woke me up out of my [__]
slumber
and uh i'm looking at myself a little
differently now
yeah i'm proud of me too i'm proud of
all you [__]
and now without further ado mr david
[__] chase
[Music]
how are you david it's a masterpiece oh
come on well
how are you i'm good good good
were you there on wednesday night no i
was there i was there did i see you
no i was 10 feet from here and they told
me to turn around and walk inside so i
didn't know
what was going on they said go in so me
and nick balalanga
walked in and then you guys went and
took a picture and i was like what'd you
make us go in for
the hope yeah that's like it's been
typical typical of this movie that
little details and things are screwed up
but it was great it was there to i was
happy to be there on your big night
our big night they loved it but it was
really your big night brother this is
all about you
i have a couple questions and i'll let
you be i know that you've been getting
beat up the last three weeks
no i haven't been getting beat up i'm
just yeah i'm getting tired yeah you get
doing interviews yeah it gets old so i
understand
i wanted to ask you a few questions it's
not about the many saints it's just
generalization and i'll let you go
number one
how much do you love new jersey
uh well i my number one answer would
have to be i don't live there
that's why you love it
i could if i um
my memories of new jersey are extremely
positive
extremely positive
and
i i i could live there very easily
right now we're living in california
because of
various illnesses in the family and
stuff but
i mean essex county i really i loved it
a lot
uh it was a great place to grow up let's
put it that way yes i was
uh eight miles from new york city
and you hit the age of 18 where the
drinking age was 18
and you drive in in new york city and
sometimes we would just go
come out of the tunnel
go around the corner there's a puerto
rican deli
buy a huge bunch of six packs keep the
car running get back in the car get back
in the tunnel and go back to jersey and
take the beer back there and have a
party
but also we did a lot of drinking in the
city yeah and the kids used to get
killed on the way back
uh all right it was a great time really
you know people always say to me these
stories that you tell
cannot be true about you growing up and
it's they're all true i mean they're all
i had a great childhood as a kid even
though i didn't have parents you know
new jersey
filled the void italians filled the void
for me yeah yeah
and uh
i never forgot it while i was shooting
the movie
i got so caught up in the whole jersey
thing that i actually moved back
yeah yeah yes i thought you were you
were in philadelphia though too weren't
you no i was in la i was in l.a when i
shot the movie but i got a bunch of
cookies from you from philadelphia yes
those are great cookies because a friend
of mine is from philly and he sends me
those cookies so i figured you'd like
those italian cookies they were great
they are great
no i mean
it was a long time ago and
it was kind of country where i lived
it was small town america like you'd see
in the movies um
[Music]
kind of country when i lived there some
people had no there are no more cows but
people had horses
and you could buy corn and tomatoes at a
local stand
what was i say to you um
now by me i live in south jersey
it's beautiful
but it's very equestrian
i had no idea that new jersey was the
number one state for horses
my wife's from tennessee and she's
excited i'm sure you've read about it
spring's teen's daughter won some
olympic prizes yes equestrian yeah she
went to the olympics or something so
yeah it's very equestrian
a lot of trees i mean i'm i grew up in
north jersey in north bergen where it's
a concrete jungle
and then to come down here where it's uh
you know just
it's beautiful
trees
deer
my daughter saw a bear a couple weeks
ago i mean it has just been uh
it's a great yesterday
they were in the sopranos neighborhood
and they saw a bear across the street
through the window a little young bear
um
that place where the
did you do we ever
no we never shot at the soprano house no
yeah
well that place was that's where i grew
up right there in that town
and
it's now a development of kind of like
big houses
that was my a swim club that my wife's
family belonged to called wildwood swim
club is in the middle of the woods
and all the
patio furniture everything was like
appalachian style you know
you could have you could have been in
upstate new york and the pool was huge
and there was nothing around the patrice
and you know they had a
soda fountain there where you could buy
stuff it's all gone it's all houses now
that's too bad
but
what are you gonna do
question number two i had for you was
these characters that you had in the
show the tv show
where did you come up with these names
and these characters i mean
you know from little from big [__] to
they were just so they stood alone these
characters the same kind of characters i
grew up with
in jersey
you know it's the same kind of thing
there was a lot of them but um
let's see
i mean tony
the name soprano came from a kid i went
to high school with
who was also the cousin of my father's
business partner an adult version
his name was soprano
[__]
i was told that by a
detective who worked for
uh
what do you what do we call them in the
state police
new jersey troopers
troopers yeah he was a detective who
worked for the troopers and i've read
about them since but
the um
[Music]
their name was
what the hell was their name
but anyway they were brothers it was
john
he was big [__] and then there was his
brother little [__] and they got the
name because they were um
uh cat burglars they used to sneak into
people's houses and steal
so that's where they got that name
i mean it was before people i think it
was before people knew that [__] was
not
had not been made into polite word you
know
now while you were writing on hill
street blues and all that stuff
i never wrote a note oh you never wrote
it how long did you have this vision in
your head
of this show
oh uh
not long
um
i was writing those other shows
and
i switched
my deal ran out wherever it was
universal
and my whole career was based on
i would get a tv development deal
so in other words for two years your
salary was paid
and you could do anything you wanted to
you were supposed to
be developing tv shows
so i would have to do that
at the same time as i was trying to
write movies
uh which they didn't care about at all
um
but if i had
made one of those movies which then
every day
they would have owned it but
um so i was going back and forth on
those deals for a long time
um and they were they were really to
help get me into the movie business but
it never worked
um
it never worked but i wrote a lot of
those things
rockford files policewoman
um cold check the night stalker
i just i forgot them all
these are all the kids these are all the
shows i watched as a kid really the
night's talk uh yeah yeah
yeah the nightstalker was did you get
scared yes
i know to us making the show wasn't
scary at all
and darren mcavon
became kind of an [__]
and
he wanted to run the whole show and my
friend paul who was the producer
who had brought me along that was like
my second job argued with him and he he
was replaced he was replaced and
gotten rid of it served at the same time
it was mutual um
and they brought in this new guy i
stayed the whole season
um and it was just you know it was and
it got sillier and sillier and sillier
that this this one guy would go out and
search these monsters every week it was
really ridiculous
well it was just that the original movie
had been great that he was a crime
reporter in las vegas
and showgirls was being murdered
in vegas
and nobody thought it was a vampire he
and he began to think that it was
because of reading
and and it was it was a vampire
and uh so after that they did another
one another movie
about that was about
and then they did the show
with a little monster a week we had to
make up monsters we didn't have enough
it was it was fun i'll take it darren
was a pain in the ass but it was fun
it was a seven day show it was an hour
show we used to shoot in seven days
holy [__]
and a lot of it had to be it was
supposed to be at night
and night shooting as you know is very
costly
and more difficult
and they want so
the new producer came in
and he said now listen
who says that a vampire can't go out in
the daytime
because they wanted to shoot in a danger
and i said you know i was just like i
said no that's not what vampires do well
i know that's what they say
but
who says there can't be a special
vampire that goes out in the daytime
and i i wanted to write a book called
vampire logic
which would explain everything from the
vampire's point of view
but i never did it but
we used to have these fights all the
um time
was really cheap
and so it wasn't to me it was never
scary
although i was a scaredy-cat kid i loved
monster stories
i'd like them to an extent
i really like them
one of the guys who worked on the show
was a guy named michael kozil
who later co-created hill street blues
and he was very funny i mean we just we
had
you know we were
brought up guys in our 20s
making fun of that stuff while we were
doing it
it was great
david last night while we were doing the
screening
i thought about something that somebody
had said they had a
somebody was asking a question
and he said that he thought it was one
of the funniest shows he had ever seen
now you and i both know that when you
wrote the show when you look at the
listings
it says a drama
you know it's a drama
how did you make this show
so f and funny because i laugh my ass
off and it's tough to make me laugh so
do what i watch the old ones i think god
this is funny how about
hard to be that way just
i i think everybody who was on the show
had a talent for delivering that kind of
thing
um
jim was good at it jim understood it he
he had some feelings of doing comedy but
i don't know
they just seemed fun they just seemed
funny to me i mean that was done like
sort of the
years
kind of the end of the mob you know
[Music]
they're getting put in jail a lot
you know drugs that really put a dent in
them because
selling and doing drugs because
there was those new rules i forget what
they were called but
the older wise guys if they stole some
money
they could do five years in jail that
wasn't you know a problem i mean it's a
problem but they could do it
but the new rules were
drug offense federal prison 35 years
and those guys couldn't take it and so
they would ride out their friends and
that's how it all started to fall apart
because i mean there i i always say this
to people i think the uh
when you did the uh whatever for
christopher moltesante when he was doing
drugs the uh
intervention
i think that is one of the funniest
things that ever hit tv that's my
personal opinion not because you're in
the room i'm telling you this that i
have
thought of this over and over that is my
favorite all-time scene on the sopranos
well all that intervention when he calls
his mother a [__] and all that i'm
dying of laughter
i'm dying
[__] you silvio you [__] all the [__]
over there and his wife and
just it was and then all of a sudden
they're fighting and they're kicking
each other
it was an intervention
right it was supposed to be an
intervention you know even though you're
a drama writer i got to tell you i
learned from you watching the show as a
comic well you know but the thing is
i was supposed to be a drama writer
those shows are called like
by
the tv academy those our shows are
called dramas
um
and
from the beginning
from the nightstalker there was a lot of
humor in it i don't know if you've gone
back and looked at it there's a lot of
stupid silly humor
cartoonish
so i got some of my chops there the
rockford vials had a lot of humor in it
smarter
more witty
not so goofy but had a lot of humor um
so i was really by the time i arrived at
sopranos that's what i knew how to do
was to write
action or drama shows or
whatever kind of show and also put a lot
of
humor in it
and i always felt that um
you know in my real life i used to see
funny things happen at the worst time
we've all seen it
um you know
and i couldn't get enough of it i love
doing it
you know it seems like you have comedic
influences
and i would have to say because i love
them also it would be
your your writing is in the bob newhart
realm
i love bob newhart that dude has always
made me laugh
his deadpan delivery but when i see your
writing
the type of non-jokes that you write
because they're non-jokes that
and uh i laughed my ass off even in this
movie
last night there was a couple things
that
a couple lines couple things that you
did
that were just brilliant you know
the italian girl when she says
[__] i almost died
oh yeah right right almost even those
little things like i would never as a
comic think that was funny you
hit the [__] nail with the situation
you know it's situation comedy really
it's uh
it's inter
it's interpersonal comedy i mean it's a
stand-up comic you're only talking
yourself right right you've got to come
up with ways you can
ways to say well this guy told me
whatever but
you know
comedy and drama on a stage or it's all
about conflict
it's all about one person believing one
thing the other person believing another
and they argue when they fight
whether it's a pleasant fight
a bad fight
it's always funny for some reason
and you hit it on
the
when like simple things like even when
in the series when the kids when tony
went out
to see what uh janice and his father
were doing and there was a card game you
know the card game breaks up and all of
a sudden you show a clown getting
arrested
how [__] funny is that
right right
a clown is getting arrested what did a
clown do
what could a clown possibly do to get
arrested the claire was actually the guy
who made his living doing clown work at
birthday parties and he was obviously a
degenerative gambler and he was down
there you know
ernie
he probably was saying well you know
what oh my god it's almost two o'clock i
gotta get out of here one more hand
yeah
no it's a it was uh
your comedy is great
before the sopranos before the first
episode hit
did you think it would ever become what
it did
no not at all
in fact i used to tell my wife
we got picked up for 13 episodes so we
made the pilots that left 12 to do
i used to tell her i'd say this thing is
never going to go anywhere
i said it's all the mob people have had
it
it's just
it's tired
but i guess what we did was different
enough
it was real
it was real kind of like you know what
coughlin means right it was like kind of
capone comedy it wasn't they weren't
wasn't um
the leones with ties and all that you
know somber [__] it was i mean i it was
believe me that was great
it was
kind of low life middle lower middle
class working class
i think a lot of people are related to
that i think people could say oh my
cousin eddie is like that
oh my cousin frankie's they say he's
involved in that
no i loved every bit of it
i sucked it all in i was in new york
dropping off tapes and my agent called
and said drop off a tape and uh georgine
walken's office for the sopranos and i
was like
i can't [__] sing and i didn't drop
it off i never dropped it off and i'm in
cleveland
i don't know a year later and this show
comes on
and i'm blown the hell away i caught it
from the last half hour
and i went home and i asked my friends
have you seen the soprano show i was
supposed to read for it right
and uh it blew my goddamn mind so
well it's great having you you were a
great presence
on that show i mean one of my favorite
things is you're you talking to joe
dimaggio i like i love that and you know
he did hang up the guys who who ran
newark the warrior family
they had a big mansion
richie bourdain
they were
they were the new jersey
crew of uh the genevieve's family i
believe
and
he had a big mansion up in livingston
and that was all true and
george raft used to hang out there
and
dimaggio so that was all based on truth
so
see and whenever it's based on real
stuff it helps i think
well i knew that you had to base this on
something something that you saw
growing up in your everyday life and you
really captured
i mean stuff that i would forget all the
catholicism
you know the wakes i've been here a year
i've been to three [__] wakes
for 23 years for 30 years i didn't go to
awake
i've been here a year i've been to three
weeks already you know i got invited i
got involved with a lot of them through
the show because people you know there's
a large group of people people would die
order a relative would die tony sarico's
mother died we had to go to the weight
and his his brother who was a priest
he gave i don't know what you to call
the eulogy or something and he said
we must believe must understand
that i was inside that body
for nine months
okay jesus
oh
david i want to thank you that's what i
mean it's crazy great it really is crazy
i know but i knew that you had written
this off your experiences growing up
and your i had my best friend owns a
funeral paula david who does my best
friend
till today we grew up together you know
how many bodies i went to pick up with
them
really oh my god how many joints i
dipped in formaldehyde you know
oh my god you have no idea
you know we would just so when you would
have all the way since i was like this
guy has hit new jersey on the head you
just hit everything on the head so yeah
well i was a kid i was interested in you
know you're interested in wakes and
stuff like that
spooky stuff what goes on back there and
i used to like thinking about it
my father told me when he was young he
was working with my grandfather
on a
funeral home in pittsburgh
i believe
and
he fell asleep
down in the room with the bodies
and um
he woke up and what the body sat up
because you know the gas inside the body
makes it move and he completely freaked
out and you know
i just loved i love those kind of
stories
i've been his friend for 45 years and he
still hasn't told me what they do in the
embalming room
right because they have to take an oath
in the movie it says that tony is trying
to sneak into where they do the bodies
he's trying to snuck in to see what they
did with bodies i was laughing when he
said that
david i want to thank you for everything
i want to thank you for what you did for
new jersey
i want to thank you for the best show of
all time oh well thank you thank you for
putting in a great movie
well i hope we can do some more and if
you want to meet joe i hope we can do
something else me too is nicole around
what she said want me to call her yeah
nicole
could you come in here
joey wants to talk to you i'm not
actually going to be in this park
she doesn't want to be in the podcast
she doesn't want to be
yes come on i want to say hi to you but
i want to say hi to you and i want to
thank david and you
and i want to tell david that you're the
best producer ever you kept us together
like glue
you were great to work with we had some
great nights together it took me six
months to get over the experience i was
heartbroken
it was great i didn't care about the
long night i love all that stuff so
and i'm really proud to be in this
project this is a great project
great so i want to thank the book you
brought a lot to it oh you you were
great dave but i learned a lot on this
so thank you and thank you for
uh reigniting my love for new jersey and
making me move back here
yes i'm here i love you guys
how'd it go last night in l.a
very good good it's a different crowd
yes but it worked well he got to hang
out with frankie valli though yes
frankie that's
yeah he lives in calabasas that's right
yeah
that was how's he doing
he looks great he's gotta be ready
yeah i don't know i think so
maybe he might be older
and he looks about
65.
doesn't it
yeah no he really didn't look very good
he looked great and he's still touring
he had a beautiful suit on
yeah
good but i love you guys good luck on
friday
we're gonna kill it
and i'll talk to you guys soon thank you
very much for coming on today okay
stay black love you bye-bye bye-bye
all right you bad [__] i hope
you enjoyed my little tata tay with
david chase listen guys he had been beat
up
for the last two weeks he's been doing
press three weeks he's been working on
this movie for two [__] years
and i know this so i didn't want to
bust his balls i didn't want to ask him
the same question that he's been getting
asked for the same you know people ask
you the same questions the last two
weeks so i wanted to switch it up a
little bit you know
i'm happy you enjoyed it i enjoyed
speaking to him
i enjoyed being in this movie and i
enjoyed being a part of this and it's
for the first time in my life i feel
like there is a real feather in my cap i
really did something i got a medal for
doing this
and i'm very proud there's a reflection
of my wife my daughter and the person
who i became
i love this movie so much this movie
got to me so much that it made me move
back
there was only one place i could live
when this movie came out
and it was [__] new jersey this
is my home
i appreciate rogan for offering me a
home in texas and all my other friends
who wanted me to go to mississippi in
colorado and whatnot
it was time for me to go home there's
always a time for you to go home and i'm
home and it was because of this movie
so go to the movie theater friday
saturday knock yourself out
and have a great [__] time and enjoy
this uh
i want to thank david chase
i want to thank all you [__]
for supporting us
and for having my back and for
supporting me and watching this film i
love you [__] with all my heart
stay black have a great weekend and i'll
see you guys monday morning
tip top magoo it'll be october
next time i see you it'll be october cox
i better not see you [__] till
october you [__] douchebags
anyway i love your [__] and now
for a word for my [__] sponsors
jack
all right i want to thank
david chase
i want to thank michael for helping me
put the podcast together today but most
importantly i want to thank you [__]
savages
for always having my [__] back
and supporting what we're doing here
david chase
is a great man
talented as [__] and i'm happy i got the
opportunity to work with him but enough
of that
the joint is brought to you by
draftkings listen
[__] you [__] bookie [__] these other
[__] services
draftkings is the official sports
betting partner of the nfl and of the
ufc it don't get no better than that
they're safe reliable and the convenient
you could withdraw your money whenever
you [__] want they got a tremendous
casino blackjack poker
roulette baccarat i mean you know you
got chinese people there standing behind
you they don't give a [__] and
football's here it's week three and
you're still [__] around download the
draftkings sportsbook app draftkings has
an offer that is [__] bananas they're
giving new customers 150 dollars
instantly joey how can they give you 150
dollars just bet a dollar on any
football game college or pro you heard
me [__] head to draftking
sportsbook app today bet a dollar and
get 150 and free bets instantly did you
hear me
if sportsbook ain't your thing or it's
not available to you because it's not
legal that's fine draftkings has a daily
fantasy contest they're giving away huge
cash prizes all [__] season long so
football ain't your thing you still got
golf you got mma you got baseball you
got college football you got so many
different options but it starts with you
downloading the draft draftking
sportsbook app today right now
like i said draftkings is giving all new
customers a free shot at millions of
dollars in total prizes with your first
deposit download the drop download the
draftking sportsbook app or download the
draftkings fantasy with the sportsbook
app listen you put a dollar in
and you win 150 on any football game use
promo code joey okay they're the
official betting partner of the nfl new
jersey indiana pennsylvania
west virginia colorado new customers
only minimum five hour deposit and a one
dollar wage is required that's it this
is a [__] gift
one per customer restrictions apply see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gaming problem listen take care of it
call 1-800 gambler if you're in indiana
call 1-809 with it but if there's no
problems and they won't be on draftkings
because you pay as you bet
you can't get out of control let's have
some fun [__] download the
draftking sportsbook app it's time to
win some [__] guitars here the joint
is also brought to you by
cbd lion when it comes to cbd there's
only one [__] lion that's it
that's it cbd lion is the cbd you should
be using whether it's the tincture you
put it under your tongue you wait 20
minutes and you relax whether it's the
cream whether it's the gel
the kinesiology tape
they got some [__] hemp
some cbd hemp that'll knock you out you
don't see it no more why because i
smoked it it helps with your anxiety
[__] suckers that's what cbd lion's all
about whether it's the kinesiology tape
the bath walls the vapor pen we got you
covered in every [__] avenue we can
cbd lion is that good it's not like
you're dealing with some [__] guy
with a ged at a gas station this is real
these are college educated [__]
people
they're the best company around so i
don't know what the [__] you're waiting
for telling me that your elbow hurts get
to cbdlion.com right now read
read everything you got coming to you
read the advantages of cbd
cbn and cby and then get back to me
[__]
go to cbdline.com preston joey and get
20 off
delivered right to your house cbd who's
better than you
nobody cbd lion slash joey
the joint is also brought to you by the
best underwears in the world in my
[__] opinion me undies comfort
comfort is their middle name it's the
fall that means you'll be pissing your
pants one way or another between the
halloween kids and [__] or you're
drinking too much at the [__] game
go ahead ruin your pants you know why
because you could buy some fresh ones
from [__] me undies
me and these are the most comfortable
underwears ever i've been wearing them
for six [__] years and that's all i
wear
no holes nothing that cotton is
tremendous me undies designed to be the
softest thing on earth softer than a
baby's butt softer than a feather softer
than a jack-o-lantern that's been
sitting in the sun
how meundie's signature micro modal
fabric literally grows on trees that
means these underwears are soft and
sustainable what's better than that
nothing
nothing they offer millions of sizes
from extra small if you're a [__]
x-ray the 4x if you're a chubby dude
like uncle joey different cuts for
different butts that's their motto you
they got bras they got socks they got
loungewear but it all starts with you by
going to meondys.com
joey because what i'm going to do is i'm
going to get you 15 off your first order
free shipping and 100
satisfaction money back guarantee that's
meundies.com
joey but make a decision quick
because there's somebody standing right
behind you
look you look you [__] mook i love
you [__] go to me undies i want
to thank me undies i want to thank cbd
lion
i want to thank draftkings i want to
thank zip recruiter i want to thank
bowling branch for having me this week i
love you [__] with all my
goddamn heart
stay black have a great weekend don't
forget to see
the many saints in newark and before you
see the movie don't forget to stop at
the ice cream shop
and get some [__] laughing gas from
uncle joey diaz is getting stronger and
stronger by the day last time i smoked
it my eye popped out
trust me you don't need the [__]
aggravation i love you guys
see you monday
uh let me know what you thought of the
movie
you're gonna love it i want to thank
david chase again but i want to thank
you guys for always having my back stay
black have a great weekend [__]
[Music]
tip top magoo
so
[Music]
you